we are told a transverse wave travels to
the right along a string they draw it
right over here two dots have been
painted on the string in the diagrams
below those dots are labeled p and q so
that's these dots here
the figure below shows a string at an
instant in time
at the instant shown dot p has maximum
displacement and dot q has zero
displacement from equilibrium
at each of the dots p and q
draw an arrow indicating the direction
of the instantaneous velocity of that
dot
if either dot has zero velocity
write v equals zero next to the dot
so pause this video and see if you can
have a go at it on your own before i
work through it with you
all right now let's work through this
together so let's think about the
instantaneous velocity of this dot right
over here and to help us think about it
let's think about what's going on on
either side of this dot so if we think
if we think about this point right over
here what's going to happen a little bit
after this moment in time we're looking
at
well the wave is traveling in that
direction so in a little while the wave
is going to look and a little a moment
after that the wave is going to look
something like this
the wave is going to look something like
this so this dot is in the process of
moving down
and what about this dot right over here
well this dot a little bit later is
going to be higher so it's moving up and
it's this point where we're at our
maximum when we're at our maximum
displacement from equilibrium we are
going from going moving down to going up
right at that moment so right at this
moment of maximum displacement we have
zero velocity so let me do that in red
so you can see it so here at point p we
would write v is equal to zero
now what about at point q
well we just sketched what's going to
happen a moment later our transverse
wave is going to look like
this
and so point q is going to be up here
so point q
is moving upwards so if we want to draw
its velocity vector it would look it
would look something
like that
now let's do the next part
the figure below shows the string at the
same instant as shown in part a
1.
at each of the dots p and q
draw an arrow indicating the direction
of the instantaneous acceleration of
that dot
if either dot has zero acceleration
write a equals zero next to the dot so
pause this video again and see if you
can have a go at it
one way to think about it is all the
points around p and actually all of the
points in this area right over here are
going to have a net upward acceleration
so even though
this point for example right over here
has a velocity downwards that downward
velocity is becoming less and less and
less as you get closer to p and then it
flips around becomes an upward velocity
and becomes more and more upward as we
get closer and closer to this point so
everything in this area right over here
has a net upward acceleration so p would
have a net upward acceleration as well
it has zero instantaneous velocity but
we're at that moment we're going from a
downward velocity to an upward velocity
so we have an upward acceleration
what about at point q well one
interesting thing to appreciate is that
everything in this region right over
here has an upward acceleration and
everything over here
has a downward acceleration and then
everything over here has an upward
acceleration and so point q is at that
transition point where we're going from
a downward acceleration to an upward
acceleration and so
here right at that point at this moment
you're going to have zero acceleration
so here we write acceleration is equal
to zero
and then it says the figure below
represents the string at time t equals
0. the same instant as shown in part a
where dot p is at its maximum
displacement from equilibrium for
simplicity.q is not shown
on the grid below
draw the string at a later time
time t is equal to capital t divided by
four where capital t is the period of
the wave
so pause this video again and see if you
could do that if you can even sketch it
out if you don't have access to this
drawing right here
to think about a full period we can look
at a full wavelength of this wave and so
one way to do it is you start at a point
and then you see well how far do you
have to go to get to the same point
again so we went up we go down where you
could say we're at the same point but
here we're going up and here we're going
down so we want to go back to when we're
going back up so that is a full
wavelength
a full wave length here is 24
centimeters
so after one-fourth of a period this
wave would have shifted one-fourth of
this length and so one-fourth would be
one of these sections right over here so
all i will do is draw the same wave but
instead of starting here i'm going to
start here 1 4 of a wavelength to the
right but then i'll draw the exact same
wave it's just shifted
so notice it has just shifted one
fourth
of a wavelength to the right and so it
will
look it will look something
like that and then if we look at the
next parts of the question
on your drawing above draw a dot to
indicate the position of point p on the
string at time t is equal to the period
divided by 4 and clearly label the dot
with the letter p
so let's just remind ourselves of where
p was before
p
is
at this point that's halfway between 12
and 24 centimeters so that's going to be
at 18 centimeters so it's right over
here so at this point p is going to be
right
over here so from t is equal to zero to
t is equal to the period divided by four
p went from down here up to here
and then last but not least it says
now consider the wave at time t is equal
to a full period
determine the distance traveled not the
displacement by dot p between the times
t equals zero and t is equal to capital
t
so pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
so we already saw at time t is equal to
zero p is right over here
and so what's going to happen over a
full period well over that time period p
is going to move all the way up to
positive 8 centimeters on our y axis and
then all the way back down over a full
period
and so if you ask this displacement you
would say it's zero you're back to where
you started but the distance well it
would have traveled 8 16 centimeters up
and then 16 centimeters back down so the
distance traveled would be
32 centimeters
and we're done